either reject nation I'm Greg I'm John
it's been the twilight zone of a day I
won't go into it he was here well so I
took a melatonin and he had a big dinner
totally suck it in right now you know I
can see the angle you can see the gut no
I can see the wrong side look guys this
child's play trailer leaked online now
I'm out of respect and also so we don't
get a copy it's good very good avoid
rapid rain down away for the official
one to go up we're just filming this now
suppose there's gonna be another trailer
in the morning you've heard something
else and then I'll get some sleep
yeah we're going off totally be super
late for the other what if a toy like
this came out now this is like a cool
[Applause]
house a good creepy voice interesting
house creepy voice yeah yeah I would
never want to hear that voice in the
dark lot of horror Jon just finished
doing stream alongs for the haunting of
Hill House on our patreon page hey that
sounds like a great segue yeah follow us
on the start of new movies trailers and
TV shows okay guys oh well John you're a
bigger chucky fan than say I what is
your thoughts on this I'm pretty
fascinated by what's gonna happen you
know like I really liked this trailer
it's I had a really great time watching
this trailer and if you're trying to I
don't know like Chucky is something that
even though I was never the biggest fan
of it I grew up with it it's very
engrained in my mind the concept of
updating anteaters on being either very
silly or kind of cool and black mary i
don't know which it's gonna be but I did
like the Menace kinda especially because
this seems like it's not kinda there are
times where I'm like I don't think I'm
supposed to find this part humorous yeah
he's like Brian's Harry Henry is about
to like smack that kid he's like you
Bert it's just like it feels like that
fan trailer of if someone wanted to do
like if child's play was remade today or
if somebody recut a trailer that was
like a happy family movie about like a
kid in his advanced toy you know doing
some magical adventure and they've recut
it to look like a hobby but it really
did remind me of Evil Dead 2013 in the
pacing and that really like cutting to
black and silence and then just like
really shuttle on oh beets and really
just hard-hitting violence what does
child's play
the idea of killer doll lend itself to
cuz I like when you compare Evil Dead
the first people that's a really serious
movie where the first child's play movie
and I don't want to just keep doing a
direct in comparison here I really don't
guys are being very sincere what I think
this could be a little bit more self
alone in some capacity getting serious
version abri Plaza here who is I think a
very underrated actress and can really
do some hardcore like you know MA
and her interacting capabilities has a
weird I really want this movie to take
her and then make Chuck Andy's mom
Tiffany cuz she would make a great
killer Chucky Tiffany exactly yeah cuz
this seems like they ant made the mom to
me where's like in the first one she's
not a young attractive woman but she's
still not attractive young
yeah it's every element of this I'm like
yeah this is the first it's hard not to
compare it though because of the fact
that this is the first it's like this is
the first child's play movie except that
all the fun camp is you know like
decidedly set apart from the original
series and so we got we good we got
talking about Chucky's new look yeah you
know I'm not upset that hellboy makeup
yeah what no I don't hate it I don't
know I haven't real I don't feel like
I've really seen much of it because I've
seen that promo picture if I recall the
first movie he gets kind of jacked up by
the end of it he doesn't get all like
Frankenstein and staples now a way loose
take some pro yeah shakes
yeah by the end of it he's all scuzz
Devon and you know a bit destroyed and
degre sure so like that is to me the
fully realized monster of Chucky and so
like to see him even when I watch the
original child's play like to see the
original good guy doll is a little weird
to me every time because it just looks
yeah like a doll in a movie see I don't
know if when child's play the first one
came out that it was self aware of its
camp when I watch it today I feel like
it feels self-aware I'm like or such as
a product of its time in here I think if
you're gonna remake something
that is it's like it looks like the same
movie just a super serious side of it
and I have a hard time taking it
seriously because I'm aware of the more
humor because I thought the first
child's play had a lot of intensity but
it's really well balanced with it with
its humor yeah or at least in the humor
and its style yeah I don't like this is
a robot toy and they're trying to like
black me yes that's the part of this
that pushes it towards silliness for me
because yeah that's the part I think
about the least when it comes to this
trailer is the fact that Chucky is like
a cybernetic future doll so and I don't
know what that means is it just like
he's an AI that goes rogue yeah or is
there a Charles Lee ray is there's some
kind of other supernatural element that
gets grafted onto that how does it look
like it's in the 80s but it's like I'm
so much interesting to me yeah like what
I don't feel like it's that's another
thing if it did have that feels like
producer knows it sure it feels like a
cake this is people love that stranger
things and interested kids working
together at the end please yeah and I
don't it's been a couple years since
I've seen child's play again it's oh I
don't remember there being like you know
losers Club styling we gotta get
together take him down like you know
it's it's mostly and the thing about the
original child's play that really stood
out the last time I watched it which was
very fresh for me was that it does a
really good job of playing in on the
horror of what if you left your kid
alone with this doll you know is it
dangerous sure if the movie can play on
that like it has plenty of menace and
horror [ __ ] in it and it looks cool and
intriguing and stuff I want to get a
sense for that I mean everything just
looks fine right now just looks really
big but what's great about the horror of
child's play is that it's very intimate
so I this kid thinks it's dolls alive
and it's fun it's killing people and
they never suspects at all but when you
make it a robot it's easy to get kind of
maybe the dog like is it gonna get too
crazy is it gonna go too over-the-top is
gonna be too black where I picture an
African not let us keep this monetized I
don't know I'm here sooner one thing for
sure Ryan
you have my ticket I'm going to go watch
I am excited to because I honestly don't
know what's gonna and I hope this movie
turns out good sometimes you watch a
trailer and you go nah we definitely and
sometimes you watch a show you're like
you know what I feel like the movies
better than the trailer yeah or at least
highly enjoyable if flawed you know
because yeah because the thing about
this trailer that I think made me think
of Evil Dead the most aside from like
the visual and sound elements is that it
does have I get the hint that there's
like a nasty grin behind the camera of
Evil Dead like even though that's a dead
serious movie there's it seems like
somebody really wants to poke characters
and I feel like this movie might have
that and I don't know I mean and the
Mark Hamill voice yeah these guys ever
talk about the Mark Hamill boys it's
just a little line right there I hear a
little bit of Mark Hamill I hear a
little bit of Joker here a little bit of
Brad Dourif yeah I heard a little bit of
them all and I'm like also how many
different voices can you do for Chucky
without you know make him like a Russian
or something like that you know go
off-road with it that was the thing
about the first child but that Chucky
dog first looks trustworthy this Chucky
doll doesn't look trustworthy at all
yeah now why'd you buy that kid that
creepy-ass the other thing is like the
the original good guy doll was they
called buddies in this movie the the
good guy doll does look just like a as
like a friendly kids doll and then he
gets all messed up later if you just
hear to that riders room we wanted to
update you know the good guys like Oh
beauty of buddy's app with this see
that's the thing though is that if the
movie will say that was the movies dumb
will say that was silly thank you that's
what I mean and the day it's just a
trailer what's the point of doing a
reaction if it's not a reflection which
you actually think of the movie yeah
welcome to the real rejects you can
subscribe click that notification bell I
feel like we covered everything except
for my my hope that the twist is that
it's it's Andy in her double down the if
Andy Dwyer comes home he's like what
happened